we move on now to a very special segment
when we award a few very special degrees
the university recognizes and honors the
monumental achievements of these select
individuals for the sum of their
contributions to their professions and
the public SMU is proud to confer
honorary Doctorate degrees on to
extraordinary gentlemen first maybe
invite the very enthusiastic vice
provost and Dean of the School of
Information Systems up on stage to
deliver the citation for first honorary
degree recipient dr. John Seely Brown
professor Stephen Villa please
good morning the singapore management
university confers an honorary doctor of
information systems degree upon John
Seely Brown in recognition of his
outstanding record as a scientist
scholar and innovator in information and
communications technology or ICT for
short for his assessments of the
business and economic impacts of ICT and
for using ICT to enhance the science and
practice of learning John has been
responsible for were involved in some of
the most significant advances in ICT
research development and practice over
the past three decades his insights and
observations on ICT trends are sought
out by private and public sector leaders
worldwide his unique way of looking at
IC developments and trends within the
broader social context is highly
acclaimed well John has been an
important contributor to IC development
through his prior work as a researcher
laboratory director corporate board
director advisor and enterpreneur he
also maintains a healthy skepticism
about whether or not change always
represents genuine progress when John
served as the director of the highly
acclaimed xerox palo alto research
center he expanded the role of corporate
research to include such topics as the
management of radical innovation
organizational learning complex adaptive
systems and nanotechnologies he was a
co-founder the Institute for Research on
learning his research includes a digital
youth culture digital media and
institutional innovation the social
context and social info
of learning and the role of Technology
in business and education John is an
inducted member into the american
academy of arts and sciences and the
national academy of education he is also
a fellow of the american association for
artificial intelligence and the American
Association for the Advancement of
science he is a former trustee of the
MacArthur Foundation some people know
this is the foundation that gives out
the so-called genius Awards he serves on
numerous public on boards including the
boards of Amazon and Corning the famous
glass company and on many private boards
of directors he has published over a
hundred papers and scientific journals
he has co-authored numerous influential
books he has received the annual
McKinsey prize for the best article in
harvard business review on two separate
occasions John received the bachelor of
arts from Brown University in 1962
majoring in math and physics and a PhD
from the University of Michigan in 1970
majoring in computer and communication
sciences now up to this point in time
John has actually received six other
honorary degrees believe it or not he's
received an honorary doctor of science
from three different universities from
Brown University where he graduated as
an undergrad from the University of
Michigan and from North Carolina State
University he also has an honorary
doctor of science and economics from the
London Business School an honorary
Doctor of Humane Letters from Claremont
Graduate University and an honorary
doctor of design from the Illinois
Institute of Technology and that's why
we are so proud to be the very first
that gives John what we think is the
honorary degree that is really most
befitting for him and that's the
honorary doctor of information systems
and why is that because what is
information systems it's not only the
of information and IT is some people
might call it it's the information
itself it's about the way people use it
it's the people who use it and the
setting in which they use it and John
has been exemplary in bringing all of
these things together and he's been an
inspiration to our school just very
briefly to mention John has been an
active contributor to our school of
information systems since 2006 when he's
been on our advisory board and i want
everyone sitting in the audience to know
that John has done his national service
and he's done quite a bit of it he has
served on a number of very important
Singapore panels and advisory boards for
our ministry of education our Media
Development Authority and our National
Research Foundation thank you thank you
professor Miller nice remain on stage
rivers we now invite the Dean of the
School of Law to deliver the citation
for a second honorary degree recipient
dr. chansik young professor yacht young
men please
good morning the singapore management
university confers an honorary doctor of
laws lld degree upon chancellor keon in
recognition of his remarkable
contributions to the development of the
legal sector in singapore as attorney
general and subsequently as chief
justice dr. chan has always been a
pioneer achieving several notable firsts
he was among the inaugural batch of law
graduates from the University of Malaya
in 1961 and he was the first Singapore
law graduates to be admitted to the
Federal Bar of Malaya in 1962 he was the
first person to be appointed judicial
commissioner in 1986 among the first to
be named senior counsel in 1987 and the
first person to have held consecutive
appointments as judicial Commissioner
judge Attorney General and chief justice
Chief Justice Chan became the first
Singaporean and local law graduate to
become an honorary venture of the
Honorable honourable society of
Lincoln's in England in 2008 then in
2009 he was the first Asian to receive
the international jurists award for
outstanding contributions to the
administration of justice and enhancing
the dignity of the judiciary in Asia dr.
chan was a practitioner when the penny
electric industries company collapsed in
1985 due to unsettled forward contracts
it was the largest coverage collapse in
Singapore's history and it forced the
stock exchanges of both Singapore and
Malaysia to shut down for three days dr.
chan was called upon to draft agreements
to extend credit from banks to the
insolvent stock broking firms these
skillfully drafted agreements restored
liquidity to the system ensure the
survival of the stock exchange and
helped Singapore to maintain its
standing as a financial center while
serving as chief justice
dr. chan was asked by the government's
to appear as counsel for Singapore in
the International Court of Justice at
The Hague in the pedra branca dispute
together with Professor John Kumar
professor Tamiko and others he presented
Singapore's case lucidly and the ICJ
decisively upheld Singapore's
sovereignty over the island as Attorney
General dr. chan proved to be firm and
fair but boat and humble he earned the
respect of the legal profession by
emphasizing the importance of an
independent bar when advising the
government on legal policy and
regulations he also established the
technological infrastructure for legal
research and services and defined to the
country's strategic legal needs on his
appointment as chief justice on 11th of
april 2006 he maintained an unrelenting
determinations to uphold the rule of law
to build respect for the integrity of
law and to ensure a fair judicial
process he also tirelessly sought to
promote cooperation amongst the
judiciary the bar the legal service as
well as law academics chansik Young's
initiatives as chief justice were a
highly significant factor in building a
judicial system in Singapore that is
equal to the very best in the world
thank you Thank You professor yo please
remain on stage with us may I now invite
dr. Chang An dr. Brown together with SMU
president professor damaia to come up on
stage with us ladies and gentlemen
please join me in welcoming them
may we now call upon SMU Chancellor mr.
young punk how to confer the honorary
degrees sir ladies and gentlemen by the
powers granted pursuant to the singapore
management university ACT i hereby
confer upon dr. John Seely Brown the
degree Doctor of information systems
honoris causa dr. Choong sik yuen the
degree Doctor of Laws honoris causa and
admit you to all the accompanying rights
and privileges Thank You Chancellor dr.
John Seely Brown if you please step
forward professor de mayo maybe we
invite you with the assistance of
Professor Steven Miller to place the
hood on dr. John Seely Brown
thank you dr. John we invited take a
step back thank you gentlemen man may I
now ask dr. chan to step forward please
professor damaia if you will do the
honors for dr. chan with the assistance
of Professor you
Thank You says
professor be Mia if you could please
take a step back thank you dr. chan
please stay on stage with us thank you
ladies and gentlemen may we now invite
Minister for education is the hang suite
care back on stage please
Minister they invite you to present the
honorary doctorate of laws to dr. Chang
se Kyung
Thank You Minister dr. Chen please take
a step back thank you dr. Brown if you
could please step forward maybe now
invite minister to present the honorary
doctorate of information systems to dr.
Brown
Thank You minister maybe now invite
everyone for a photograph on stage
Thank You minister professors dr. Brown
and dr. chan we value back to your seats
you